das ist Key United vom inneren Reportage
über mich dunkelretreat und
Mercy Film mal für die viele viele
Rückmeldungen Kommentar Feedback
allgemein und ich bin mega schön sieht
wirklich viel Frage aufgegangen und die
werde ich jetzt da Sachen beantworten
ich hasse solche
technisch also so wie ich das ganze
aufgenommen wie das auf mich gewirkt hat
denn allgemeine Frage rund ums Retreat
und denn solche persönlichen
emotionalerie Frage die Frage wo glaube
ich am meisten gestellt wurden
ist doch tatsächlich die richtige Salome
erfragt wie hilfreich ist sie zum
Kameraden bezahlen also einerseitig für
mich eigentlich Prozess aber auch zum
das also ob es einfacher gemacht hat
eigentlich sein aber andere Frage und
ich muss sagen
sind einfach gemacht dass ich während
Bezugsperson gehabt und ich mache damit
Dusche aber es ist gleichzeitig auch wie
es Probleme sie vielleicht konstant denn
du das denkt hast was nämlich alles auf
also es ist wie so eine die einzig Hürde
eigentlich gesehen
vielleicht so knappe Stunde deine als
einzige und ich besetzt
wir machen das Video so gut wie möglich
[Musik]
besser also
Angst
dass das wo nie irgendwie mitmachen
nicht gut genug ist und das ist wirklich
nur so zwei Tage wieder gegangen bis ich
mir dann selber Zeit habe ich muss
wirklich weniger Filme weil Schuss bin
ich einfach konstant mit dem Film in der
selber wo ich ich muss irgendetwas
machen anstatt einfach mal erleben und
dann wieder draus verzählen denn das
zweite Problem wenn man dem so wird
sagen wenn ich haha ist das Infrarot
Licht auf der Kamera damit man mich
überhaupt gesehen hat und ich habe das
ja auch gesehen und das ist aber genau
frag vom JFK ähm was ich im unternimmt
das Infrarotlicht Warnung wenn ich
brüllen nicht aka an einfach die Antwort
ja das habe ich gesehen selber sondern
mega mega
[Musik]
wo halt nicht so optimal ist
und darum würde ich glaube ich
einfach die Augen abdecken wenn ich rede
wir sind seit besonders
aber dafür nimmt man mich besser wahr
über die Augen und und ich kann mich
dann einfach so viel entschieden wenn
ich es gerade auch irgendwie sehe dann
ist kein Problem
gemacht Robin die wusstest du dass die
Kamera aufnimmt wenn du kein Bildschirm
sehen konntest ich kann dir Kameras die
High Vorsicht gegangen bin komplett
abklappt und mir braucht wenn ich sie
muss anschalten wenn ich dann muss
drücken wenn ich weiß dass sie aufnimmt
weil dass ich wieder
umschalten ohne dass ich
irgendetwas
überhaupt aufgenommen
alles aufgenommen haben
ob ich überhaupt aufgenommen habe wenn
ich einfach Knopf drückt haben ob ich
richtig im Bild bin als
scheißgefühlhof
richtig gedrückt an und sowas nachher
Tatsache im Nachhinein gesehen
kann dass ich auf Stopp drücke ich
eigentlich erst auf Start drückt haben
und so sind wir wirklich 30% von der
Aufnahme einfach du Finger bitte
Überwachungskamera wo oben sie ist aber
anders gesehen und die Kamera die nimmt
auf Bewegung auf das heißt hinter dem
Vorhang ist nicht sobald ich davor
anziehe nimmt sie auf da kann ich wieder
zurückziehen und dann stellt sie wieder
ab und das Licht und das scheint so in
Ruhe sondern es ist schwer man kann
das Licht rot glühen eigentlich aber
nicht sondern das Licht wo irgendwie
nach der ganzen
Sache wäre es nicht deutlich wenn man
gar kein Zeitgefühl hätte die Mahlzeiten
können ja zum Beispiel alle
bereitgestellt werden für eine Woche das
habe ich Corina gefragt und sie hat mir
geantwortet dass es extrem schwierig ist
zum irgendwie das retweetmacher ohne
dass man
gesagt wir müssen wirklich in den Bunker
gar oder irgendwie eine Höhle wo man gar
kein Bezug mehr zu der Osterwald hat
also auch komplett Schall isoliert und
auch das Inge Frischluftzufuhr Hund weil
man immer irgendwelche Art Punkt wo wir
sportlich also es ist ja ob das
Spannende ist
kann man darüber streiten das zweite wie
erledigte man das abputzen beim großen
Geschäft mega einfach also entweder man
putzt einfach so lange
gut oder sogar
eine komische Frage
aufmachen nicht alle Fenster eigentlich
speziell gab wo nicht sozusagen mit der
Lade zurück sie ist und tätig
man hat das mit also mit dunkelbrille
ankleid und hättest den aufgemacht
alle anderen
fragt wie war das mit der Wahrnehmung
von unterschiedlichen Geräuschen also
chrischanisch viel viel extrem zum Teil
wirklich wenn ich Fenster aufgemacht
haben
mir wenigstens oder zu habe wenn ich mir
auch dass du für mich quasi einfach
nicht handeln es ist so extrem und denn
die Jonas Weber fragt hast du jemals
gewusst was es zu essen gibt oder musst
du das selber herausfinden ähm wir sind
losgegangen ist wenn man das Formular
bekommen
was man alles weg
die Haferflocken zubereitet weil oder
was in dem Smoothie inne hat und das
heißt das ist eigentlich eins von der
größten Highlights Sitzung versuchen was
jetzt genau der innen ist
denn deine Mutter fragt was heißt am
meisten vermisst in der Woche und die
Frage kann ich auch von meiner
Kolleginnen und Kollegen recht oft
gestellt bekommen und eigentlich so
komisches dünnt
also wenn ich mich so fest so mental auf
das vorbereitet hat dass ich gar nicht
wird
hätten wir auch wirklich nicht gefällt
klar erster Tag oder so ist vielleicht
mal so gesehen ich würde jetzt gar nicht
essen gesehen oder allgemein kurz ein
bisschen gesehen relativ schnell wieder
verbieg gegangen also ich kann wirklich
eigentlich praktisch nicht vermisst weil
auch Bezugspersonen
mit der Kamera ich kann mich nicht
Gedanken
darum kann nicht wirklich vermisst
wirklich nicht denn solche emotionalerie
oder persönliche Frage der alte Mila
Achille fragt hey Robin sehr spannende
Doku aufgrund meines ADHS passen alle
Eindrücke meiner Umgebung jeden Tag auf
mich ein wie bei dir nach dem Retreat
eine Woche Reizung zu bringen klingt für
mich deshalb paradiesisch meinst du
respektive Psychiater als ein solches
Retreat für Menschen mit dieser Diagnose
förderlich sein könnte die Frage ob
sondern es wird verliebt mit ADHS hat
förderlich sie hat mich am
Psychotherapeuten Arnold Witwer gefragt
habe und er hat folgendes geantwortet
Eric geschrieben es ist schwierig
unseriös hier eine Empfehlung abzugeben
wir wissen nicht wie ausgeprägt das ADHS
ist und ob noch sogenannten
Nebendiagnosen vorhanden sind was
meistens bei ADHS der Fall ist ich würde
ihre empfehlen sich fachlich beraten zu
lassen und dann falls möglich diese
außergewöhnliche Erfahrung für sich zu
machen Elif fragt hattest du auch
depressive Verstimmungen oder ständige
Müdigkeit oder waren diese Gefühle nicht
so im Fokus ich muss sagen
ab dem 4 5 Tag bin ich wirklich einfach
auch recht oft einfach nur immer Klage
also
sehr viel nur Klage aber besonders
Passivität und lustigerweise ist das
Gesicht
gegangen bin
[Musik]
depressiv gegangen oder so und das ganze
fragt nämlich ob ich Mini Ansicht auf
meine Vergangenheit war oder ob es mir
Kurve hätte die Sachen verarbeitet weil
nämlich
negative Erinnerungen
ihre Kinder
teils wo das ist im ersten Moment
in dem Moment den auch nachher wenn ich
es nach der Kamera nachdem ich es
verzählt habe ist mir so viel steif vom
Herzen okay das ist es hat mir das in
dem Moment Kurve zum das Verarbeiten
aber ich kann ganz ehrlich jetzt jetzt
nach nach zwei Monat kann ich jetzt
nicht sagen das hätte sie mir
irgendeinen Knopf aus der Vergangenheit
gelöst also ich glaube es ist viel viel
mehr und es ist jetzt schwierig zum
sacken wow das hätte jetzt das alles
irgendwie einfach aus dem System gespürt
und denn die letzte fragt vor jeder
Kontakt hat möchtest du das Wiederholen
ganz einfach seid ja aber das mal ohne
Kamera und das mal auch gern zwei Wochen
und vielleicht
zwei Wochen hä nein das ist wirklich so
gesehen
wirklich chillig bei mir gefühlt dass
ich gar nicht haben müssen mache dass
ich gut und gerne zwei drei Tage länger
drin bleiben
danke vielmals und für mehr so Videos
abonniere das